foreign
good afternoon everyone
my name is Dr Miller and the SCP we're
going to be looking at today is scp-4188
anomaly class
Euclid
special containment procedures samples
of scp-4188 are to be stored in standard
pharmaceutical grade storage containers
no other specific measures are required
for long-term storage
testing of scp-4188 is limited to
Personnel who score 95 percent or higher
on Foundation loyalty tests should it
become necessary to neutralize a Target
under the effects of scp-4188 and
injection of adrenaline preferably
delivered at range has proven to be
effective
repeated testing of scp-4188 in the same
location is prohibited and public spaces
where repeated use of scp-4188 is
suspected are to be investigated and
dispersed as necessary
attempts to find the manufacturer and
core distributor of scp-4188 are ongoing
description
scp-4188 is an anomalous pharmaceutical
compound distributed under the name warp
intended for use as a sleeping pill a
person under the effect of scp-4188 will
begin experiencing vivid dreams upon
entering an unconscious State and
reality in the areas surrounding the
person will be altered to match the
dream these changes to reality include
the creation of entities and objects and
full topographical alterations to the
surrounding area the person will then
begin sleepwalking and interacting with
their surroundings as they do in the
dream itself
effects of scp-4188 began approximately
one minute following ingestion and last
for 50 to 70 minutes following this the
person enters a regular sleep State
though they may continue sleepwalking
any changes to reality caused by someone
under the effect of scp-4188 persist
until the person wakes up which
typically takes four to eight hours
following the cessation of the primary
anomalous effect it should be noted
however that these reversions have been
observed to be incomplete in areas where
use of scp-4188 Is frequent the effects
of long-term use in a concentrated area
are unknown but should be avoided
scp-4188 is highly addictive to people
that suffer from insomnia and other
Sleep disorders and long-term abuse
causes the human body to lose physical
cohesion affected parts of the body
begin to break down and fall away as
particulate matter this process
typically starts at the extremities and
moves inwards in extreme cases people
have been observed to dissolve entirely
people in the vicinity of someone under
the effects of scp-4188 who aren't
themselves affected generally find
navigating the altered environments to
be difficult and confusing following the
use of scp-4188 a person waking up will
consider the experience to have been a
regular dream memories of the experience
fade quickly in many cases and some
people possess no recollection at all of
what occurred
testing log 4188 1. the following is a
section of log summaries taken during
scp-4188 tests due to the inconsistency
in recalling dreams upon waking each
subject during testing is assigned a
researcher to attempt to document the
experiences in as much detail as
possible
subject agent Rosa Martinez
results immediately following the
activation of
scp-4188's effect a number of entities
manifested around the subject and they
began talking the facial features on one
of the entities were indistinct and the
words being spoken were unintelligible
though the subject claimed that these
entities were members of her family
following the conclusion of the
conversations the subject turned and the
interior of the testing chamber was
replaced by a rocky outdoor landscape
bright flowing lights could be seen
hovering in the air and a number of
other planets or moons could be seen in
the sky the hovering lights began
singing in Russian and then rapidly flew
into the sky shortly afterwards large
explosions could be seen on the surface
of the other planets which began to
crack and then dissolve into glowing
dust
the subject then approached a small
building with a single door upon opening
and passing through the door the subject
was in a classroom surrounded by
children being taught by a person the
subject claimed was their middle school
art teacher the subject sad and
participated in the class until the
effects of scp-4188 ended
the subject and the accompanying
researcher were later found in the
subject's Middle School approximately
700 kilometers from the location of the
original testing chamber
subject researcher Frank Trammell
results the testing chamber was
immediately replaced with a complex
series of dark tunnels lined by pipes
and cabling and some form of energy
weapon manifested in the subject's hands
he proceeded to run down one of the
tunnels and shortly after fired his
energy weapon at a black quadrupedal
entity with a human face later
determined to be his mother's
following each kill he would speak into
a radio claiming to have bagged another
one which received an incomprehensible
reply
after approximately 10 minutes of this
Behavior the subject found a door which
led outside onto a green field at noon a
yellow bus pulled up alongside the
subject and a number of entities
resembling classic mythological monsters
disembarked they sat at a table and
proceeded to play a game of poker in
which the currency being used was the
teeth of the participants the game
continued for 50 minutes during which
time the subject lost approximately half
of his own teeth but won a notable pile
of teeth belonging to the vampire and
Frankenstein's monster after a final
hand the subject declared himself the
winner and proceeded to replace his lost
teeth with those he had won during the
game to the consternation of the others
the subject then stepped onto the bus
the door of which led to a bedroom three
naked women were on the bed which the
subject approached he began to disrobe
at which point the effects of scp-4188
ended and the subject fell asleep on the
bed the researcher accompanying the
subject contacted the site shortly after
to report that they were in the
subject's bedroom approximately one
kilometers away
subject agent Roger southwell
results shortly following the onset of
scp-4188's effect an entity bearing a
resemblance to site director Ford
entered the testing chamber the subject
immediately attacked and began viciously
beating the entity this continued for 57
minutes The Entity remaining alive and
conscious during the entire processes
before the effects ended and the subject
entered regular sleep
subject has been referred for
psychological examination
operation Riding High
in an attempt at employing the effects
of scp-4188 in a way beneficial to
Foundation activities a number of
experiments were led by director Shirley
Gillespie involving the use of scp-4188
by Foundation agents skilled in lucid
dreaming the project proved initially
successful as the agents were able to
gain some significant control over the
reality manipulation abilities provided
by scp-4188 unfortunately following the
first scheduled field test and incident
418805 operation Riding High was deemed
too risky for regular deployment and the
project was terminated
see incident log 418805 below for
details
incident log 4188-05
three agents under the effects of
scp-4188 were deployed to a suspected
warp distribution warehouse as part of
operation Riding High the operation
began cleanly as the agents were able to
exit the site-119 testing chamber and
directly enter a small side room within
the warehouse at which point the
warehouse and its occupants became
subject to the effects of scp-4188 used
by the agents
using the effects of scp-4188 they were
able to sufficiently distract the
occupants of the warehouse to allow the
agents to neutralize a number of them
stealthily
at this point one of the targets began
exhibiting scp-4188 effect having
apparently taken a dose as soon as the
commotion began the conflicting
intentions between the agents and the
Hostile Target caused a panic state in
everyone under the effect of scp-4188
leading to a loss of control by the
agents
the resulting chaos caused by four
conflicting dream states led to a number
of large-scale events witnessed by and
involving significant numbers of
civilians in the surrounding areas the
range of effect of scp-4188 during this
was increased significantly Beyond
normal during these events
events of note include
a manifestation of the Moon appearing in
the sky above the warehouse and rapidly
descending towards the surface before
stopping above the water nearby
thousands of human corpses in various
states of Mutilation then began to fall
from the Moon impacting the water and
surrounding docks
the appearance of eyeballs from a
variety of species in the sky each of
the eyes continually cried blood and
produced a screaming sound that could be
heard throughout the affected area the
eyes were observed to track the
positions of any people visible to the
sky
the manifestation of a large
approximately 10 meters long skeletal
Serpentine entity which sought out
nearby humans the Flesh of anyone nearby
would be anomalously stripped from their
bodies and applied to that of the
serpent entity victims remained alive
and conscious during this process
the teeth of all humans in the affected
area violently burst from their mouths
and onto the ground nearby before
rapidly regrowing and repeating the
process the teeth then coalesced into
vaguely humanoid forms and began
assaulting the nearby populace
this lasted for the full duration of
scp-4188's effect before response teams
were able to reach the agents and wake
them using adrenaline shots triggering
reversion of the effects
alongside the agents a number of pieces
of equipment were recovered from the
warehouse each Pace primarily consisting
of a humanoid entity with a rotary phone
in place of its head
the corn of the telephone was connected
to a glass tank in which a purple fluid
was being collected
the design of the equipment is
consistent with that known to be used by
the wateroy collective
the resulting cover-up these events
required cost thousands of man hours and
millions of dollars operation Riding
High was terminated and the Agents
involved and nestorized at their request
okay I think that about does it for
today
thank you all for listening if indeed
you still are and you are all dismissed
sleep well
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to
big sip
tomothy
zargaron
the Morrigan
James Saba
oh crop guy
heroin sick
11.
fire of prime
and D versus the world
Spencer arduin
rubbish Ben 69
Dr Wolf 13.
cubster
worthy fire
zazapan
Lemke
signor
alatreon
your local Foundation agent
derivative
Lost Boy
and Lyndon B Johnson
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the volgan
thank you